[Musique]
extrait du dernier rapport du conseil
économique et social sur les
travailleurs étrangers les estimations
les plus courantes indique qu'une
présence étrangère globale en france aux
derniers sondages d'environ 3 millions
100 mille personnes l'accroissement du
groupe des étrangers est de l'ordre de
7% par an soit dix fois le rythme de la
croissance de la population de souche
française il est admis en principe que
les travailleurs étrangers doivent jouir
des mêmes droits que les français sous
quelques réserves fin de citation
en camargue quelque part près d'arles un
village de 900 habitants mas thibert où
il y à sept ans pour des raisons autres
que la pure recherche du travail sont
arrivés avec leurs familles 800 éleveurs
aujourd'hui français musulmans car ils
ont choisi la nationalité française
c'était des arcs nous avaient suivi leur
leader le match à gabes boualem ils se
sont installés à la lisière du village
avec leurs coutumes leurs habitudes
leurs traditions
les activités des harkis pendant la
guerre d'algérie et leur nécessaire
installation en france ensuite ancré en
fait un double problème d'adaptation
aujourd'hui la guerre d'algérie est en
principe oublier les enfants vont à
l'école les jeunes essaient de
travailler
quant aux anciens eux ils essayent de
subsister autour du bashung
s'est passé avec la population
[Musique]
s'est très bien passé il ya peu
tiraillements avec les néo français
c'est à dire par exemple raconte les
origines italiennes ou espagnoles le
nouveau français est ce qu'il ya eu des
accrochages de des bagarres il ya une
seule fois
alors on a formulé donc des reproches ou
aux harkis sont là le projet d'être venu
ici d'envahir le village bien entendu
nous étions mal vu voilà les français
musulmans donc qui sont installés là
cancer ou leurs coutumes les femmes ne
sortent pas et c'est à
nos femmes bienvenue chez qui ont un
certain âge il est inutile de faire
quelque chose car ne voudront bien faire
et croyez-vous que une intégration sur
possible quand même elle est possible la
preuve c'est qu'en arrivant à l'école
c'est qu'en 16 et 18 ans vont encore à
l'école donc je pense que l'intégration
est possible et elle se fera un don à
l'école même surtout pas j'estime que
c'est un bien car nos jeunes nos jeunes
enfants et surtout les filles n'ont pas
encore l'esprit assez mûr pour pouvoir
sortir seul et il ya trop de tentations
pour les jeunes vous êtes un goût une
certaine rigueur mais
cette rigueur morale j'en suis partisan
et vous ne croyez pas que ça puisse être
un frein à l'évolution des jeunes qui
s'installent non ce n'est pas un frein à
l'évolution des jeunes qui s'installent
je pense que dans huit générations il
n'aura plus rien à envier aux ailes ans
et de france
frédéric 16 ans filles 2 articles six
frères et soeurs elle porte un prénom
français parce qu'elle a choisi
elle-même à 14 ans de se faire baptiser
pour mieux se mêler du teil à la
population française échapper à son
milieu s'intégrer
est-ce que vous fréquentez par exemple
facilement de jeunes européens oui
et comment ça se passe vous avez vidé
les rapports amicaux normaux gentil ou
bien est ce qu ils vous font sentir que
vous êtes d'origine musulmane
monstres qui sont gentils sympathique
toujours
qu'elle
met vos parents par exemple s'il savait
que vous fréquentiez régulièrement à
genève et à quelle serait alors la
réaction
je crois qu'il se rende pas d'accord
pourquoi elles vont enfin savoir
c'est à dire qu'il fait avant je fais
comme je continue à faire notre région
par exemple se marier avec un homme tout
ce qu'ils voudraient oui vous ne voulez
pas non
non ça vous savez que votre père peut en
principe vous obliger à l'épousé alarme
oui et c'est par exemple ça se passe
quelle serait votre réaction
je serais pas d'accord on alors qu'est
ce que le riz mais
est-ce que vous partiriez de chez vous
est ce que vous iriez ailleurs en fait
qu'est-ce que votre notre position en
soit je suis pas d'accord pour le
mariage mais votre père alors qu'est ce
qu'il dirait
écouter qu'est ce que vous pensez
justement de cette obligation
comme parfois les jeunes filles
musulmanes d'obéir à leurs pairs et de
prendre leurs maris qui leur est imposé
dites moi ce que vous en pensez de ça je
trouve que c'est pas bien parce que elle
connaît même pas le jeune et s'il
n'oublie pas mais je trouve que la vie
pour aller ce sera très dur
frédéric tout en travaillant au chan a
décidé d'étudier ces jeunes français
sont en cours avec elle avec le times un
câlin finir par s'intégrer et même la
population française si elle a quelques
réticences qui a fini par accepter c'est
à dire que les gens vont finir quand
même pas
parler considérés comme des gens comme
nous justement quand il ya un problème
d'éducation élevé d'éducation ils
doivent parvenir à se considérer
normalement et les contacts sont
naturels avec jeunes européens
ça c'est probable pour faire pour vous
cette solution oui vous êtes d'accord
assez réservé justement parce qu'elles
ont honte et
moi je vois par exemple rappelle
elles nous font des rédactions où il est
question de description de la maison etc
elles prennent toujours un endroit
extrêmement
moderne avec des meubles dernier cri
enfin elles ont tendance à vouloir
copier les les européennes dans le tout
au moins une famille européenne dans
tout ce qu'elle a comme confort et comme
oui comme organisation de vie à la
française
c'est au compte de ce qu'ils achètent
elles et moi j'ai vérifié la véracité de
leur dire si vous voulez en allant chez
elle et je me suis rendu compte que des
meubles il y en a très peu que ces
misérables elle rêve d'une promotion
c'est elle la concrétise par un
intérieur moderne
français je sais ça le jeudi samedi
après midi le dimanche matin et on fait
ça pour quoi pour cela me plaît j'aime
travailler aux champs j'aime être avec
des
ouvriers
comme blague
cet argent qu'est ce que vous en faites
je les donne à mes parents et puis c'est
pour continuer mes études aussi
vous posez l'exemple du clochard
ou non
bon et de l'argent non
parfois voulait pas toujours
alors que le chômeur annie
alors se réveiller
[Musique]
cherche du travail bien sûr
en ce moment mais je trouve que les
petites qui sont en commun cette petite
part qu'ils sont les meilleurs de la
classe parce que elles sont très
travailleuse très volontaire envie
d'arriver ils ont envie d'arriver à
quelque chose alors que les autres
s'endorment inquiet lorsque vous aurez
terminer vos études
que comptez vous faire
je compte partir d'ici tout de suite oui
pour lui
d'aller vers le nord c'est à dire c'est
un gars
puis des coups par une paire les
alliances trésorier ou paris vous
connaissez paris sinon c'est vrai que
c'est très difficile parfois la vie à
paris
ça fait rien oui voulait échapper à la
vie que vous avez ici oui qu'est ce qui
vous déplaît ce que c'est un
environnement c'est la région sont les
gens nous sans les gens je trouve qu'ils
sont un peu raciste comme en mai et
savez vous aussi dans d'autres régions
par exemple mme à paris les gens ne sont
pas éventuellement un peu raciste
candidats je trouve que les gens
n'auraient sans gentil qu'ici quand vous
avez vu oui pendant les vacances vous
avez vu des gens ici oui
et que comptez-vous faire exactement à
quel genre de métiers
comptables vous pensez pouvoir trouver
du travail facilement
je sais rien j'ai très peur pour elle
parce que par exemple je suis allé chez
un employeur en lui disant j'ai une
sténodactylo qui est extrêmement rapide
avec est très très bonne quand il a vu
que c'était une petite arabe il m'a dit
je regrette mes propos ne viennent je
vais employer une arabe je préfère
donner du travail à une
française il ya une espèce de
racisme larvé alors on vous dit elle a
pris la racaille en employer ce mot
suite du rapport du conseil économique
les besoins de logement des migrants et
leurs familles sont très importants si
l'égalité d'accès aux hlm avec les
français est théoriquement reconnu aux
travailleurs étrangers les
discriminations d'honneur dans la
pratique
les critiques actuelles c'est que j'ai
journal ne peuvent pas s'assimiler
comme il devrait le faire puisque nous
leur tendant la perche constamment au
pouvoir sa chimie la loue mais ils
vivent toujours que dans l'orne dans
leur milieu
et qu'est ce que vous appelez vous
l'assimilation
l'assimilation c'est à dire que de
prendre un petit peu nos habitudes nous
avons voulu les initiés dans dans nos
associations
principalement dans le
chez le comité du haut comité de
l'amicale
l'amicale de la cité natale devant mr
ben les vérités réticences de leur part
mais c'est de réticence manifeste enfin
ils viennent parce qu'il viendra qu'il
n'y ait pas aux réunions quand il ya les
andré liens que nous avons vu le maximum
que nous avons vus comme indigènes
c'était peut-être huit à dix jours de
mai en question sur monsieur pourquoi
employer vous le mot indigènes
on emploie le mot indigènes le jeu parce
que ça sonne nous avons l'habitude que
les apl d'hygiène mais c'est dur comment
ça se passe entre les enfants il se
mélange avec les petits européens mais
la fin est ce que ça vous le trouver
dommage parce que vous l'appréciez
comment est ce que vous trouvez dommage
que les petits algériens fréquentent le
zoo européen ou quoi oui parce que vous
savez il est certaine elle
certains certaines son père ils sont pas
fréquentables
qu'est ce qui vous gêne par exemple dans
l'immeuble que vous habitez orchies rien
ne me gêne pas du tout parce que le
généralement le français reste reste
chez lui il ne fréquente pas ces gens là
une rue de montreuil près de paris
sept personnes dans chaque pièce
[Musique]
il reste toujours
attaché à leur milieu et il évite un
petit peu leur contact alors qu'ils
n'ont jamais eue d'inciter pareil dans
leur pays
on le croyait au pacte qu'il y ait une
sorte de complexe quand même vis-à-vis
des français que c'est pour cela
peut-être qu'il ne fera pas comme ça
qu'ils ont accompli les français
d'ailleurs je ne peux pas dire ce que je
pense exactement pourquoi dites le alors
ça serait aller à l'encontre de deux
buts que nous recherchons
une discussion dans un centre de
formation féminine étrangères entre deux
leçons
[Musique]
en amérique on dit que ce soit des gens
racistes quand vous êtes noir vous allez
en année les vous faites attention mais
en france ce sont des gens soit disant
pas raciste et au contraire qu'ils sont
des fois très raciste seulement et ad
je ne sais pas quoi il faut faire
attention ne vous pas se rentrer dans
les détails mais il y en a qui soit
raciste egypte pour vous montrer
l'exemple de raciste il ya un jour dans
le métro en face de moi y avait une dame
pimpante bien habillé j'arrive elle
avait son sac alors c est demandée racer
parce que j'étais un peu fatigué et bien
cette dame était géniale regarder
d'abord bloor le pied et puis elle m'a
dit mais vous sortez de chez vous pour
venir demander
mais tout l'argent que vous donne qu'est
ce que vous en faites
mais rome
ne connaissait pas peut-être gérer
demandé aux européens de venir les
colonisés chez moi que vous cherchez me
plait enlevez tous vos bagages au
capitole revenir chez doivent se
débrouiller tout seul et qu'elle
assortit sa distance et je me suis
assise elle s est levé elle a été plus
loin mais là pas trouver de place assise
et puis moi je pense aussi que les
français ne soient bien pour cesser le
racisme parce que quelquefois dans le
prêt d'y rencontrer un petit français
avec sa môman il vous touche et puis le
voici sa mère loi odieux que sa maman
lui donne une petite correction est
milieu du rhin elle ne laisse ce qui
fait les enfants ils grandissent avec
cette motion la et sur le plan logement
parce que vous avez des problèmes
d'habitat fontenay le fleury et je suis
obligé de venir ici tous les jours j'ai
cherché un logement partout mais je
n'arrive pas à trouver quelque chose à
chaque fois cosy de venise quand mon
mari a un humiliant des égards c'est un
noir pour lui de céder jamais et réussir
il est obligé de partir
m6 qui arrivent il dit [ __ ] dégage
caisses maladie
ça aussi je passe et puis je n'ai rien
dit puisque je suis dans leur pays avec
la plupart du temps je ne parle pas
parce que j'ai père comme les frappes ni
que les jeunes se rassemblent autour du
moins ici j'y passe mais vraiment c'est
vraiment du racisme
à marseille l'une des meilleure
organisation du genre en france
l'association de travail en outre mer
est ce par tous les moyens de former
d'éduquer puis d'intégrer lentement des
étrangers en les mêlant dans les
ensembles aux locataires français
c'est ce que vous pourrez tenter les
femmes algériennes qui se trouve dans
votre immeuble lorsque vous et on espère
ainsi revenir six mois il me manque
quelque chose je vis de mal être prêtés
volontiers
comme ça se passe pour moi c'est assez
non non non vraiment pas
pas du tout chacun chez soi et
le rapport du conseil économique et
social
signale que 92% de la population des
bidonvilles sont d'origine étrangère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on reçoit si par exemple j'ai eu il
m'est arrivé une catastrophe on est venu
si j'en à ce sont venus ils m'ont bien
rendu service mais après c'est fini
chacun chez soi
[Musique]
oui on peut pas discuter avec des femmes
algériennes comme on discute avec les
femmes françaises à ce casting est
possible enfin du thym comprenait pas le
policier et quand vous leur parlez
il ay comme paneriai mois ils savent pas
il parle dans le vide vous leur
expliquer quelque chose pourquoi c'est
beaucoup à faire et ça vaut rien il en a
pas parlé leur expliquer comment vivent
les français
et non pas les mêmes opinions sur tout
va discuter d'une chose une offre et le
bayonnais que nous sommes bien à sa
maison quand même à la réalité algériens
qui vivent quand même bien qu'ils vivent
comme les français mais qui va le
défendre c'est fort
chacun a sa maison
les étrangers ni le rapport
expédie chaque année 2 milliards de
francs dans la fuite
[Musique]
je devrais pas d'inconvénient à ce que
ma fille sont avec une fille algérienne
vous savez les filles françaises qui
est avec un algérien
[Musique]
en arriver jusque là bas nous
une alliance paraît assez de fraîcheur
pour se marier régis toile
[Musique]
personne ne se cache que l'installation
des travailleurs étrangers en france
pose de multiples problèmes on vient de
le voir et qu'il faut donc éliminer les
ghettos ethniques dans lesquelles il
s'enferre en tout sur fond ans ferme
première solution l'école l'école
classique comme un mas thibert où tout
se passe bien car les enfants ne
connaissent pas encore le racisme et
pour l'enseignement rapide du français
on utilise maintenant le système
audiovisuel comme dans les cour credif
de l'éducation nationale
[Musique]
pourquoi c'est tomber d'ici la fin
du mois j'osais ce qui arrive cette
saison mais qu'est ce qui arrive est
qu'elle avale
la wii elle a mal mais lui il est
persuadé que vous êtes fan de passer
alors vous qui est ce que laval joseph
strick oui ou est elle mal aux mains tu
sors tu répètes josette enfin à la main
romain au genou et montre moi tes genoux
oui mais toi une fois
oui mais mes genoux parfait aller
voilà ça va très bien est-ce que tu
habites loin de l'école
qui sont 70 langues et amis pour aller
voter
[Musique]
dans certaines usines les membres des
comités d'entreprise eux mêmes donnent
après le travail des leçons tour c'est à
leurs camarades étrangers autour
on
va répéter les mots qu'on a déjà eu
vo et
autour
qu'est ce que tu as là dessus
chausseur
chaussures je disais alors on prend la
chaussure et on la met dans la case
dans les usines les rapports entre
étrangers et français sont en général
assez bon les problèmes ne sont pas à ce
niveau
dans les grandes villes généralement on
les paye au même prix quand ceux ci ont
une profession
assez qualifiés mais beaucoup d'ouvriers
étrangers qui travaillent sur contrats
en province touchent des sommes chez les
entrepreneurs qui varie entre 3 à 3
france 3 france un compte un ouvrier
français ne travaillent jamais en
dessous de 5 francs pour faire le même
travail
et il en perd veut monter à paris où il
gagnerait peut-être un peu plus et vous
l'aviez beaucoup de poussière qui vivent
dans des baraquements en bois et manche
en prenant leur manger sur un feu de
bois par terre et ils ont très peu de
frais parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas se
permettre mieux
les problèmes peuvent se poser entre
ouvriers au moment du chômage
[Musique]
est ce que vous croyez que ceux des
français peuvent s'en vouloir à les
étrangers de prendre le travail que
pourrait faire et bien il y en a
quelques-uns c'est probablement des gens
qui se laissent conduire par des
impulsions et je pense qu'ils sont très
peu nombreux j'ai déjà entendu des
ouvriers protester comme quoi il y avait
des étrangers que ne trouvait pas de
travail mais quand on leur expliquait
qu' on pouvait dont il travaille tout le
monde en organisant les choses un peu
mieux qu'elles le sont actuellement et
bien à ce moment là les gens et qu'ils
comprennent ne disent plus rien quoi
puis-je plus de mal d'étrangers à ce
moment là carlos portugaise 29 ans il
est l'exemple de cette frange que
constituent les ouvriers étrangers
professionnellement formés mais qui se
heurte encore à des obstacles d en
france depuis quand
depuis le mois d'août 67 vous êtes
arrivé comment par quels moyens je suis
arrivé par le train
[Musique]
survenu vers le passeport touristes
je me suis installé d'abord en quand il
atteint à paris c'est ce que vous avez
eu des problèmes oui un peu pour la
recherche a toujours maintenant
champratel mais celle d'un pays en moi
religieux semaines pour que ça devenait
plus en plus ou moins cher alors qu'il
ya eu une histoire avec une dame de
notaire qui nous avait alloué déjà de la
chambre
dans laquelle nous pouvions faire la
cuisine c'était très beau parce qu'on
faisait déjà nuit je ne pouvais pas
dépenser mais sitôt qu'elle a su que
nous étions des portugais nous nous a
refusé l'achat la paf dure depuis un
mois et demi après j'ai trouvé on
attendait après une chambre pas cher je
n'ai pas trouvé dans un disque un moment
j'ai trouvé
l'ami portugais qui m'a dit qu'il y
avait un patron ici à chelsea à sa mort
qui pouvait me faire la 80ème accepté
comme troisième faire leur travail je
suis venu il m'a donné le logement
et nous paie un tout petit peu puisque
je ne trouvais une ps1 deux fois par
semaine oui mais voilà logement il était
très gentil parce que vraiment je ne
travaillais pas pour lui et un mois et
demi après avoir avoir faire la 81e à sa
mort j'ai trouvé ici le travail dans la
magie théo ensuite autre femme vivre
avec vous en france on le pouvait on
sentait qu'on prépare iront loin devant
l'autre
donc je suis une salle c'était pour
enfin de préparer un peu le chemin pour
la vie quoi qu'est ce que vous voulez
rester vivant en france
mon travail que je fais en france là ce
n'est pas bien le travail qui est je
suis prêt à faire un kg vos frères pour
tous quand j'étais mécanicien d'aviation
j'étais en afrique aussi aux services de
travailler dans des avions dans la fosse
et a procuré un par un en france j'ai
jamais réussi à avoir un emploi dans les
airs dans les usines d'aviation
se pose un problème de temps donné que
j'ai fait un travail qui ne voulait pas
aller mais si vous trouvez un travail
qui vous plaît vous resterez offense oui
si tout changer au portugal que feriez
vous j'allais vraiment il faut préférer
vivre partisans de change est arrivé
aussi je trouvais en france un portugal
ce que je suis j'ai déjà trouvé en
france c'est à dire
et avec avec un blues le travail que
j'aimerais alors là j'en ai
encore mieux se former et se défendre et
défendre si ses compatriotes c'est à
dire un nouveau prolétariat carlos a
décidé de se syndiquer le militaire afin
de comprendre le monde où il vit
aujourd'hui
alors là on n'a pas compté
[Musique]
mais
oui bien sûr m vous êtes un militant
syndicaliste pourquoi
ces deux militants syndicalistes et ça
j'avais eu le désir importantes et même
des fois on trouve des schtroumpfs ya
des choses qui ne peuvent pas digérer je
ne connaissais pas tellement les
syndicats français je connaissais un
petit pour la société de la cgt sud et
fo mais disons que les leviers
politiques
comme je n'avais pas la liberté les
avoirs éventuels aux fragilités toujours
au premier rang narré par les verts la
sauce place au sport alors j'ai trouvé
un copain de la cgt qui travaille ici
encore avec moi c'est lui le chef de la
section amical et on a commencé le
travail syndicat dans l'entreprise on
avait vraiment besoin
que sa part au niveau d'intégrité
contient 10 et puis notre et
il faut les motiver et
[Musique]